[Music]
boom what's up everyone welcome to
simulation your host island sake on we
are going to be talking about the future
of masculinity we've referenced this on
the show before but we are really going
to be taking it deep in this show today
we have dill Thomas bond joining us
thank you so much I'm so happy to be
here it's such a pleasure to have you on
the show I'm so grateful that we got
introduced that witty women in
technology international yeah we love
that group a community so strong and we
did a whole interview series with like a
dozen prominent women it was so
refreshing to be there and just like the
power they're so real yeah a lot of the
people there have gone through so much
more than the rest of us and are at the
top of the world on top of the game
really in the technology space yes yes
and that is another part of the power so
what you get through but also like what
you've achieved as well it's like yeah
yeah okay so you have a really cool
background for this so you have so for
the last like it's like how many years
has it been of really being in this in
this space my entire adult life yeah I
was like 18 or 19 years old basically
yeah yeah it's almost like 15 years
right yeah I started of being sort of in
the triage space of like how do I assert
myself and helping and sexual violence I
had a very good friend who experienced
sexual assault and I had to kind of be
there with her through that process of
healing and trauma overcoming and
survival and reintegration and in that
process I realized there weren't any men
involved and to me sexual violence is a
men's issue so at a young age I started
questioning masculinity where all the
men
yeah if we're not going to stand up and
solve this problem so at that age it was
triage how can I be helpful how can I be
helpful and there's this allegory that
is in our space about where men that fit
into gender equality and ending sexual
violence and allegory is about a village
by a river and the village that all the
people in the village notice that there
are these people who keep drowning in
the river they're calling for help so
the women and children start running out
to help pull these other women and
children out of the water and they're
helping them survive eventually the men
in the village figure out something's
going on this is a this is a trend and
they start lining up to help by the time
they line up to help the women have
already figured everything out about
survival and they say to the man go
upstream go figure out what's broken why
are people falling under the river so at
that age at 18 I started learning
upstream is about masculinity the
culture of what's broken about
masculinity yeah and that's that that in
itself the fact that you discovered that
when you're that young is really
important because I think for someone
even myself I'm you know 26 now and I'm
still like what is going on with like Oh
why'd why am I just now really starting
to understand what like objectifying
women versus like understanding their
heart and their soul and thinking about
them that way first like why am I really
just realizing that now like why does it
take that long
a shunt should be right away the child
the culture cultural programming gets to
the kids at such a young age so I would
love to yeah I was really excited for
the rest of our conversation so okay so
at that age then how did you go from
that to the better man conference and
good men project inclusionary leadership
how did yeah how the fun will happen to
get there yeah so I went from like
wanting to put my finger in the
and hold back the tide - oh I need to do
something more can I be Batman like can
I show up and start preventing sexual
violence and I started looking into that
and that seemed impossible I'm not gonna
be Liam Neeson right off the bat that's
just not gonna happen I couldn't be in
enough places and even if I got a
thousand men in a thousand other places
to be lea means that it wouldn't be
enough
so I began realizing there's something
cultural going on and the only way to
cure this to fix this is to prevent it
get way out in front of it so I started
working in domestic violence shelters
trying to understand what does
prevention look like where does the
systemic issue start is it starting with
boys when they're young is it starting
with men when they're like a what at
what age and at that point I started
learning well we have to as men start to
sit around and have a conversation about
our broken culture we have to start to
understand why we're violent we have to
start to understand where that's coming
from in order to do that you have to
have men who are willing to open up be
emotional at times it vulnerable I have
a conversation about things that can be
very challenging there's no guide for
this there's no like never before has
there been a questioning of masculinity
on the scale that we're experiencing now
so that took me down this road of
gathering men I've been doing for since
I was 18 once a week at least 40 men
plus sitting around a room we're hiking
together or doing a conference about
what it means to be a man and so the
good men project and other sites came
from that the better man conference came
from that gathering men and saying
what's broken what can we fix what's
possible to change what would that look
like if we changed it and I believe
right now we have an incredible
opportunity that you look around and I
get freaked out obviously like the rest
of us do that masculinity clearly talks
that clearly broken things are wrong and
it's easy to get down I can do that I
can get into that spiral but I have to
remember and I think this is true that
the golden age of masculinity is not
behind us it's not in the past it's in
the future so that's where the better
man conference came out of what can we
do
make a better man Wow
[Laughter]
yeah okay so the future is the golden
age of masculinity and and we were what
we're doing with the past like you said
you started gathering individuals to
have these men to have these hard
conversations about what's going on in
masculinity and this requires a lot of
vulnerability a lot of openness to be
able to communicate about these things a
lot of willingness to change and
transition to respect women
give equality of opportunity to women
people of color to diverse opinions
neurodiverse thoughts around the world
and this actually this was very
interesting we were talking about before
the show I think it's really important
to press is that you know in Africa
there is just a black man that's
oppressing black women in many ways in
Asia it's an Asian man oppressing Asian
women in many ways and so the South
America Latin America you know the
similar similar things across the world
the masculinity this is not just a white
man but it is in many ways a white man
as well well just because the virtue of
the power of American culture white
masculinity exudes a lot of space like
it just takes up a lot of space in the
world
yes but masculinity in general is a has
been a tribalistic concept the idea of
gender is still kind of new you know
dissecting what gender is and how it
affects us in our daily lives I mean
feminism is not not even 120 years old
at this point yeah it's been through
what three four waves at at this point
we're at the very beginning of that for
masculinity so feminism has dissected
feminine what it means to be a woman in
so many different ways and masculinity
is still trying to figure out how to
talk we're still trying trying to figure
out the language to use I mean we are
still there's some people in our space
you call it masculinities as in there's
a plurality of possibility within
masculinity the interesting and so we're
still the language forming state
yeah and why not it makes sense when you
start to think about it of course
there's more than one way to be a man
yeah yeah yeah in in many ways we see
that dichotomy Illustrated that contrast
is with a man that is very stoic or a
man that's very vulnerable or maybe
there's so many of these different ways
like a woman can also be very stoic a
woman can also be very vulnerable like
you know right I think we're entering a
culture of nuance or we have to yes like
there's a gray area in all of this space
and the mastery of any of this is the
balance so understanding when to be
direct and when to be open
yeah right there are times when
leadership needs to be point A to point
B the quickest possible solution and
there times where leadership needs to be
collaborative creating consensus opening
up to as many options as possible and so
the balance of that is really where
mastery comes in and that's the culture
we have to now we have to engender that
culture otherwise you know masculinity
could be the thing that tips us off as
doomed as a species because we can't we
can't collaborate like we have to fix
masculinity because we have to fix
humanity like there's so much buried in
masculinity they we can't fix for that I
like using the word argument a lot okay
we gotta like augment masculinity I like
that too yeah it's like really positive
forward moving type thing of course it
has to do with integrating the traumas
and stuff as well but that's like
augmenting masculinity to be
masculinities like you were pointing at
as well so now there's this whole like
past present and future in walks like
you're saying we're it's a resonance of
renaissance of nuance absolutely yeah
yeah Renaissance of nuance I like that's
good TM I've been saying it's the next
generation of gentlemen i I just like
that
but but it's it's modernized like
something's changing within that concept
- yeah we're in a Renaissance period
which means we're gonna change period
which means we don't know what the
future exactly looks like we just know
that it has to it has to involve
collaboration the world that we live in
now is forcing collaboration and it
should right that's the way that we're
going to get through any of the
challenges globally that we're gonna
have it's the way that we're gonna deal
with poverty it's gonna it's the way
that we're gonna deal with any of the
issues present masculinity is a net
traditionally is about isolation it's
about tribalism it's about us versus
them and so you can see how that is in
the way of global cooperation global
collaboration a global coalition so
masculinity has to shift from I'm gonna
protect me and my small tribe to
recognizing that survival involves
collaboration with the whole yeah it has
over evolution well for a long time you
could say survival was just about your
small group mm-hmm but that is no longer
true so the the guys who are like
masculinity is about survival and
self-sufficiency and all that is totally
relevant actually it's just that
self-sufficiency now requires
collaboration because this the self or
the tribe has now evolved as much as we
can as close as we can to the borders of
the earth yeah yeah yeah
to the globalist yeah boundaries are
breaking down and masculinity is one of
the things that hold boundaries in place
yeah yeah that's very interesting
okay so feminism 120 years roughly
roughly and it's like kind of like a
pendulum in many ways of swinging in
some different directions and so we had
this like feminist feminists this kind
of like divine feminist uprising
uplifting that's occurring and that
being seen in like things like me too
and all these other ways of like I saw
fortunes most powerful women conference
and I was like I reached out to them
right away I was like oh this is amazing
like I was like watching two very
powerful women on stage speak and I was
like listening to them and they were
speaking so intelligently and I love
that and I just see it happening you
know I see the transition so okay so
this is the past goes back
evolutionarily before hundred twenty
years as well but and I was talking
about the present but give us a little
breakdown of your understanding of the
past and the present well I think within
masculinity or Ted of its relationship
to culture masculinity was sort of based
on these sort of pillars that we call
the man box in this space like you can
get into this it's a structure of its
own masculinity and it's built on a few
pillars like so that self-sufficiency is
when I keep mentioning hypersexuality
heterosexuality homophobia domination or
using violence to get what you want
aggression and violence toward women
these are things that were part of the
man box and for a long time those were I
would say shadows of what we really want
from men right look we do want men to be
in a way self-sufficient right we do
want men to be strong in a way but
there's pieces of that that were left
out so now I think we're in a space of
recognizing that you can have more than
just the shade that is violent the shade
that is aggression you can have direct
assertion and have that also be empathic
understanding emotional intelligence
around you reading the data and saying
you know what I'm going to be direct and
assertive and that does not include
violence because I'm aware of this so
there's things within the man box that I
think we want to let go of and in the
present there's a fight some people want
to keep that because it feels
comfortable here in a cave and it going
out of the cave is scary so there are a
lot of men who are in the man box and
it's very scary for them to leave it the
people who I think like we are willing
to go out of the cave look around see
what's possible explore other
opportunities
we're changing the way masculinity
operates and so in the future it's gonna
have to be collaborative luckily I think
it's going to set us free as men the man
box could be very confining and there's
recent research that shows men who more
adhere to the man box than other men
those men tend to be more violent toward
others and more violent to themselves
they create more self harm situations
like suicide like alcoholism abuse
things like that
so the future looks really bright once
we get past this change period which is
very turbulent you like how you went to
the man box to describe the past and
present and future yeah and and are you
and I like the the cave the allergies
really good so sorry to use right yeah
what what are the what are the pressures
that are keeping us in the box and then
how do we kind of like release those
valves yeah you can kind of see it
happening all around us and the politics
and in the corporate game as well
there's there are rewards for appearing
masculine and this is true for women as
well we've seen that women in leadership
roles tend to exude more masks
traditionally masculine roles and so
what is it it's uh it's they're less
agreeable they're willing to like
challenge more and stuff like that so
Sheryl Sandberg has a great piece about
how if you see a man being assertive
he's a leader if you see a woman being
assertive she's a [ __ ] and that is
partially true and also structurally
created by us like we create that in the
way that we operate time for both them
to be leaders right exactly and also for
when men are overly aggressive were
angry like this is one of the areas
where masculinity is a real is really
breaking down I think
we're starting to be allowed to have
other emotions than just anger and lust
anger is kind of the only thing men are
allowed to do at work right and if
you're angry at work it's oh he really
cares he's passionate about the company
or he's passionate about the team or
he's passionate about the product or
whatever it is where if a woman is angry
she's really not allowed to have that
emotion right she sort of tamp down
don't don't be angry that that's not a
good leadership quality so this is again
where masculine he starts to get wrapped
up in other pieces of our culture
leadership itself is sort of layered
within masculinity so you're rewarded
for being more masculine at work you're
rewarded for being more masculine in a
lot of ways in our society and you're
clearly rewarded for being more
masculine in things like politics yeah
yeah okay so so part of the valve system
is that we're rewarding the structures
that are keeping the box together yeah
so part of the ways one of the ways that
we know we can break this down is by
creating a more space for women in
leadership roles in corporations women
in leadership roles in politics women in
leadership roles throughout our society
the cause what happens is it it creates
diversity of thought throughout those
spaces but it also allows role models to
exist for younger women for girls
mm-hmm yes so yes that is tremendously
important to see it be it and also
getting the neural diversity of thought
Trudeau apparently put I think 50% onto
his cabinet and I think that was a
controversial thing to do because it a
lot of people were hoping to see people
of comp of competence in those in the
domains that are needed filled in the
positions not just a you know you need
to fill a certain amount of people of
certain color or gender or whatever into
those boxes rather
and I don't know what do you think about
think you're asking about tokenism and
the challenges of tokenism yeah one can
you teach us about that oh yeah so one
thing that we know is in structures of
leadership if there's only one person of
a certain intersection and intersection
being person of color force of a
different religion than the majority
anyone even who's in an out group or an
other group this can be women as well if
there's only one of those types of
people on a leadership at the leadership
level it can be very challenging for
people underneath that group to rise up
because they only see there's one role
so there's a competition the more space
you create for people of a minority
group at the leadership level the more
collaboration exists and the more likely
meritocracy is to actually take hold
within your organization so white men
tend to think that they live in a
meritocracy in fact a large percentage
of white men believe they live in a
meritocracy yeah where the reality is
the structural inequality around them
has kept black women has kept minorities
out of their space yeah so the
opportunities to rise the opportunities
to grow aren't there now the women who
do rise up into these positions of power
have typically gone through way more
barriers or obstacles than the men and
that I think says something about the
the when Trudeau allowed people into his
cabinet who were women or who were
outside of the majority group those
people have probably fought very hard to
get to those positions yeah is it are
the smartest people always in the best
roles I think that's a questionable
interesting idea how do we find a
balance between putting the always
putting the smartest person in the role
and also having neurodiversity how do
you know what's the smartest how do you
know what's the smartest I mean this is
the other thing right like what we've
prized as smart what we've prized as
leadership positions or possibilities
has been traditionally masculine traits
who's to say that that's correct who's
to say that the smartest thing isn't to
be more feminine in leadership in fact
Gallup found out that women happened to
be better managers of other women and of
then so why why do we believe that being
masculine is necessarily the best way to
be and the bias in that is invisible
it's hard to see it but I think it's
it's obvious once you start to step back
and go oh the the things I think our
leaders the things I think are traits of
leaders happen to also coincide with
what I think men are and when I step
back from that and realize I need to
open up my concept of leadership it also
means I need to open up my concept of
masculinity yeah you could see the
threads just tearing apart right yeah
the whole fabric of society is built on
this yeah Wow yeah cuz I'm you when you
when you have the word meritocracy and
then you're trying to see the variables
that are holding people back from
ranking themselves up in a meritocracy
then then that's like a really important
thing to calculate but then you also
look into like what is the most
intelligent person for the job
you know how much research have we
actually been doing you were referencing
a couple studies about this and I think
we just need more of those to best
understand I agree there there are a lot
more studies happening now and there
were even 10 years ago
just today McKinsey and lean and
released their women in the workplace
report I haven't even gotten to read at
all I was reading it on the way over
here there's great research happening
now and all that research points to a
diversity at the leadership level is
better for the entire company even if
the best person isn't even and isn't in
the top role having a woman in that role
can be valuable for the rest of the
company possibly more valuable than
having a the top person in that industry
in that role Wow okay so that's that
would be the evidence that we would need
to yeah look it look through because
because the number one argument that I
get from the other side is just that oh
there's no evidence about it and I'm
like okay but we need to try it to find
the evidence there's a preponderance of
evidence at this point there's a
preponderance of evidence UC Davis did a
report in 2015 they entered
six-hundred I think public companies the
ones who had higher gender
representation at the leadership level
performed 300 percent higher on return
on equity than the companies with the
average level that's the average versus
the best that's not even the lowest
versus the best so the companies that
are outperforming are the ones who are
doing well with diversity at the
leadership level specifically within
gender hmmm that's in the youth that's
UC Davis that's based in the US there
are tons of studies over in in Europe as
well University of London has done one
the IMF has done one there are really
there's no evidence to the contrary at
this point hmm so maybe what Trudeau did
was actually beneficial I if anything
it's a I think a lot of people think of
it as a symbolic gesture and yes it
certainly is a symbolic gesture but it's
symbolically wise gesture the
opportunity for Canada is that they now
have an entire country full of young
girls who believe that they can become
the best in their field so they're going
to strive to become the best in their
field and I think that's a long game win
and even in the short term I think it's
a win interesting but I'm not an expert
on Canadian politics so but you are an
expert on you know on on all of this
information that you're communicating
right now well we're especially
regarding the studies that you've been
bringing up and you said that there's a
ponderous of evidence in the direction
so that's there's a yeah I I this is
exactly what we need to be talking about
how so what so what do we do what do we
do okay we're weird on this box and the
box sure where the valves are slowly
tweaking them so that there's the
pressure is leaving this box and we're
walking out the cave and we're looking
around for other things maybe some of
those other things are like you know
actually filling up positions of
leadership in the meritocracy very
qualified people that are of neural
diversity and skin diversity from
culture of different cultures and did
thought diversity et cetera
neurodiversity most important and you
can have an old diversity for being a
woman or being a man or being a person
of color etc so I like to blanket it
under neurodiversity sure but there's
symbolic interaction between gender and
culture
there's symbolic interaction between
race and culture so neural diversity is
valuable in and of itself but also the
symbolic interaction of those genders
and races is valuable within any
organization you're right yes so we hear
about that yeah the other thing I would
say okay what do we do yeah so the first
step is that any guy who wants to be on
this sort of good side of this right has
to start to break down their their
personal bias and privilege and the way
that I do that is by determining where
my intention is different than my impact
so for instance whenever I am in a
conversation with somebody and they I
offend them let's say I offend somebody
because I'm ignorant to whatever I've
just said being offensive you my initial
reaction to that is to defend my
intention yeah you know always yeah
exactly
because cognitive dissonance right now
I'm not a bad guy I'm a good guy so my
first thing I'm gonna do is I'm gonna
say oh I didn't mean to hurt your
feelings or don't take that the wrong
way or it was just a joke or any of
those defenses whenever I start to catch
myself in that space I have to start to
then question what is the impact of my
work what is the impact of my actions
that point I start to empathize at that
point to connect right yeah asking
questions like I didn't know that I was
that that would impact you that way can
you share with me what that impacted you
like how that impacted you yeah and what
happens from that is connection boy
that's where everything started it
starts to shift right at that point men
start doing individual work their own
individual work and that allows us to
start to do more of the community work I
love that okay so so there's this sort
of process of of looking at the
situation differently it's just an
Augmented perception of each situation
that you're in in a situation more of
maybe inquiry into someone else's shoes
and all and
standing of the world their perception
rather than just having a perception
that's seen the judgmental
unidirectional so there's that and then
I just want to also say that we kind of
live in an outraged culture right now
sure so it's it's a little bit I think
important to distinguish like if
somebody is offended to of course ask
and get to know why but at the same time
like if someone you know offended that I
ate a fish and they're pescetarian you
know or whatever like sure they're not
yeah that they don't eat fish they're
vegetarian yeah so like there's all
these like weird ways people can be
offended nowadays and that that is that
is kind of harming us
I don't know it costs me nothing to ask
somebody how I've impacted them it costs
me nothing it's only positive because
you time oh okay but it costs them time
and I don't ask so the time is still
spent the question is am i involved or
not and I want to be involved if I can
be now the reality is yes you're gonna
offend some people for instance the
first time I ever did an interview on
CNN we were just talking about this 15
years ago or whatever I went home to a
bunch of hate mail and death threats
from men who thought that I was letting
everybody down by saying masculinity
needed to be changed no I offended a
bunch of people yeah yeah that was
challenging for me to deal with that
impacted them negatively the reality is
there are a whole lot of other people
who are impacted negatively by
masculinity being broken so I had to
weigh out the utilitarian cost there it
is challenging to do this work we do
live in outraged culture if you're in
the me to and time's up systems if
you're kind of paying attention to that
it can be challenging to go okay how do
I act how do I act sexually if I am a
man who is attracted to women how do I
do that without being offensive and the
reality is the more open we are to
connection the more open we are to our
impact the more likely you are to
succeed in all of that I've had so many
feminist icons women who Gloria Allred
who's like that one of the toughest
women out there in the feminist movement
she's the one who said on my website you
look you sound as if you're the leader
of men of quality because the reality is
I just asked a bunch of questions like
what does it mean if
I say this how do you feel if I say this
I got a lot of really great feedback and
she saw me as an ally at that point yeah
it's when we hide within our own
attention and we hide within our
defenses that I think we lose
opportunity to connect yeah I like that
way to putting it you're hiding from the
ability from the deeper connection
potentially that exists you're staying
in the cave the box okay interesting so
okay so now
okay now the valves are the pressures
going we're what is like an ideal way
that this that the man does go out and
seize the opportunity you said that you
know change our perception and we you
know care more about the their
perception and then what else is going
on there where are we going with that
future yeah I think the next phase is
that men have to start to collaborate
with each other we have to start to talk
with each other about what does it mean
to be a man and am i hurting and not
talking about it are you isolated and
not telling me can I be helpful for you
like there's this opportunity for men to
start to be in communication and
communion with each other at that point
we started to do our own work yeah right
we can't expect women and people of
color to do our work as white men we as
white men have to do our work so go join
like the mankind project has groups of
men all over the world then you can go
be a part of and probably tonight just
go sit in a group of men who are willing
to be vulnerable and talk about their
stuff as dads as leaders in their
company as as men and after that we can
start to do things in our organizations
in our in our religious communities in
our in our roles in society but we can't
do anything unless you start first with
yourself I always say there's three
steps introspect yeah get to know
yourself what are you about what's your
thing respect so start to respect the
person sitting across from you or the
people around you and then connect and
connect means connecting with the person
but also connecting yourself with all
the actions around you and how can you
be a force how can you do like
buckminster fuller's that be the trim
tab
on the ship mm-hmm introspect respect
connect three steps respect respect
connect there's there's something in the
air that's just wanting to like hold you
know there's something that wants to
hold it back there's another thing that
wants to explode it forward and that's
so interesting that that how do you with
the introspect respect connect connect
how do you find a balance between going
forth and being vulnerable but also
going forth and retaining some sort of
the of them of the one of the
masculinity that can potentially help
with leadership as in a different way
sure I grew up on John Wayne masculinity
right I grew up in Texas kicking down
doors and having gunfights and stuff
that was my idea of masculinity but now
as a kid it wasn't later until later as
an adult when I started to look at John
Wayne as a person and the way he chose
to play certain roles the roles he
really cared about the one of the only
role he really ever fought for was in a
movie called the quiet man which is
actually based in Ireland and it's about
him going home to his sort of mothers
immigrants home and reintegrating into
an entirely new culture and in that
process he comes to terms with the fact
that violence has been the totem-pole of
masculinity forever and he wants to be a
pacifist John Wayne plays this role of a
man trying to reinvent masculinity this
is in the 30s 40s and the concept that
he came up against was so challenging
that he had to had to fight through his
own willingness to fight so yes of
course we're going to need to be
vulnerable with other men with our
spouses with our kids with the people
around us but at some point we are going
to have to be men in some ways like in
in ways of like for instance last night
I was at home and you know something in
the house fell made a loud sound I got
up I'm the one who got up and running
ran around the house trying
protect the house that's always gonna be
in me but why why do I care I think
every man who's ever gotten up in the
middle house and tried to defend the
castle if they ask that question that
deep down truth is they love the people
there with they feel vulnerable with
them through the safest people that they
can be around and they want to protect
them so there's nothing there's nothing
not strong about being vulnerable
vulnerability is where you find strength
that to cover of a book of
vulnerabilities where you find strength
and yeah the example there's been an
evolutionary process that's made it so
that we respond to the loud noise by
protecting yeah yeah and then this is
never gonna go away
yeah but then there's there's like the
well why doesn't someone else like I
don't know like why doesn't maybe your
partner stand up and go like I live in a
very awesome 50/50 relationship and my
partner got up in the middle of night
with me and she had her phone in hand
with 9-1-1 and she went room to room
with me but I was the one carrying the
sword you know and that is okay it is
okay to still want to ride horses and
kick down doors but knowing where your
vulnerability interesting yeah
lies that's a yes okay so then it's like
the children that are being born into
the world get equality of opportunity of
playing with all the masculinities and
femininities and they get to figure out
what works well vibes best with them so
I think masculinity is becoming an art
whereas it used to be this very it used
to be a role you were assigned and you
had to play it and there was no way out
of it
and I think that's the man box it's a
trap it's very challenging to be a
hundred percent Macho Man it's
challenging to everybody around that
person and it's usually detrimental to
the guy himself so I think the
opportunity in front of us is beautiful
I mean I love the way I live my
masculinity I get to be vulnerable I get
to be strong I get to be everything in
but
and why not the only thing holding us
back from being more feminine or being a
different kind of masculine is the
structures around us telling us don't do
that do this don't do that do this don't
do that yeah and we use words that are
typically feminized in order to tell you
not to do things don't be a [ __ ]
don't write don't these these words are
specifically about being feminine versus
masculine just think they're wrong
they're out of date
it's time to try something new yeah yeah
yeah that I like how a lot of this comes
back to trying something new and
exploring what exists outside of the
cave holy cow okay so the there's so
much there's so much and I'm having such
a good time talking about this because
it's it is it's so difficult to figure
this out but I think you're making it
very relatable there's a lot of people
that right now I feel are pressuring me
to potentially say something along the
lines of like well if you open up all of
the opportunities of masculine nice and
feminine ease to every single child is
born to the world
well is it a possibility that a child
will get misguided by that that they
won't be able to identify who they are
as easily because they are they're being
pressured by society to be more of
something that they are not potentially
that they could be the opposite at times
I don't know when I walked into college
I didn't know exactly what I wanted to
be I walked in with an idea of a major
and then I spent a couple of years I
went to a bunch of different classes I
audited a few classes I finally decided
I wanted to do communications because it
was this great connection of so many
different of the things I liked it had
philosophy and it had business it had
sort of a design aesthetic within it it
had language it had so much within it my
point in using this allegory is that
kids presented a whole lot of options
are gonna find their way and we can
create a whole lot of options for them
and they're going to find their way I
think the challenge for children right
now
we present a very limited amount of
options and if they're not specifically
within them they're chastise or kind of
kicked out it's like the blue or pink
yeah yeah yeah
so does it does it feel hard to raise
kids now I'm sure it does I don't have
children oh my god I'm sure it does but
I also think there's a whole lot more
opportunity for your kids now than there
ever were before yeah thank you Ron
there's a lot of opportunity to explore
for kids and to see what's best there
anyway I can go on there's so many
people that have said that it's crazy
that there's only blue and pink but then
there's so many other people that say
that it's crazy to just purposely take
your boy through the girl aisle or your
girl through the boy aisle or whatever
that I that that is it's so 5050 in so
many ways I'm Eric and I care so much
about openness I care so much about the
copernicus moments like the one percent
what is the one percent saying that 99%
is actually wrong on rather than like
just a 50/50 s that are just butting
heads against each other so if your
two-year-old picks up a guitar walking
through Toys R Us or whatever the
equivalent is these days does that kid
necessarily become a musician maybe but
if you tell them no don't pick up that
guitar they're never gonna explore it
that's a good way to put it
so let the kid explore things that's a
good way to put it and this is true as
adults as well why not explore different
things like we I think it's so
pigeon-holed as adults I have a whole
spreadsheet of stuff I want to learn and
I have it all categorized things I love
the idea of different languages the idea
of different skills and what why not
keep going with that lifelong learning
how do i tax that's what we do right
what would you say is another good
example with the guitar that was a good
one like what else is another one
like if you say that no you can't play
with this because it's not the right you
know gender or skin color religion or
whatever it's just that anything that is
foreign to the family can get the kid
home the trouble just thinking about a
koron versus a Bible or whatever like
right thinking about that like a kid
that wants to look at another book of
religion might not be able to because of
yeah getting hurt for doing so not
allowed so why you know what's the
danger and the idea what's the danger
and the exploration I don't know if
there is maybe I mean if they're
exploring the self-mutilation okay stop
them well yeah yeah oh yeah yeah did the
date the danger could be that they that
they that the that the cult of attention
around that object loses a viewer we use
as it loses attention right yeah so I
think this this comes back to
masculinity in that we have been taught
as men to do one specific thing and that
is you know be men and within that it's
pick a role within society and be that
and be that until you're dead basically
let that do you to death and I think
that has to break as well and this is
part of the collaboration with within
ourselves we also have to collaborate
there are pieces within us we've shut
down voices we've said no to that we
have to open up to and that opening up
allows things that I think are really
beautiful
for instance music I've picked up music
as a 32 year old I picked up a guitar
I'm 34 now I'm picking up piano I was
told know that I used that as a personal
example but the idea that we have an
opportunity as men to start to break
down and say well this I want to keep
from masculinity I like this this feels
good but this I'm gonna let that go and
I'm gonna try some other things
mm-hmm and it you could just it's just
like trying on a shirt at a store I
don't like it okay take it off there's
nothing wrong with trying new things
within masculinity yeah yeah I I like so
this is a tons of masking these tons of
feminine ease tons of gray area tons of
things to pick and select and choose
from to figure out how to best mold
yourself into the world and then I like
the example of a color
wiill we've been using that quite a bit
now on the shows just all seven
half-million humans are different colors
on the color wheel so not like one color
is better than other colors right is
that word different damn colors right
yeah right I like that too
that's good okay cool I'm glad that that
resonated I'm trying to come up we're
trying to come up with these analogies
that best represent like I also heard
this one recently too is that you're you
have an e you have an equal soul to
someone else but your time might not be
as valuable as that other persons
there's some really strange to say that
huh it's like you can have a bunch of
people pulling on someone's time that
might be like a leading spiritual figure
or whatever whoever they are and that
way their time is more valuable than
somebody that is not as high of a like
leading figure I think you're talking
about time and power in the same
sentence yeah the power to influence the
power to change something if I were to
help people whatever that power is is
sort of chunk down into time element
like that's the unit okay power yeah but
the stools are food he's strangely
equals so the leadership up here in the
leadership here even though they have
different levels of power the souls are
equal but the time is not worth the same
it's very strange stuff just yeah I'd
have to argue with that one for a while
probably but I like the ideas and I like
the idea of them of kind of the wide
array of equality of opportunity to the
different masculine nice feminine ease
well yeah if you go down that road what
happens is you start experimenting and
finding there's parts of you you didn't
know were there and he starts to open up
to being more fully present within
yourself and I think it allows you to
then empathize with other people has you
have more nodes more connection points
to other people so it allows you I think
to be more inclusive within your work
environment within your family within
anyone around you so opening within
yourself this is why this introspect is
first step for me introspection is about
finding the pieces within you and
allowing them to be present which allows
other people to then be more
psychologically safe with you and then
that culture is what we want right if I
go to work I want it to be safe for the
people around you and for me yeah yeah
yeah yeah loving caring harmonious with
the mission of the company but also with
the employees that are building it and
the customers that are using the product
and it's being stewards of the world
right Dale there's there's there's also
a there's something about this that I
need to ask about because it just I
think it's a just a crucial part of this
it's a it's that it's like it's the
education around this what does a parent
do to open their child to the different
emasculating seminaries etc at a younger
age so that they don't get put into the
box
yeah rather the box never exists
we know that children learn by example
by role modeling right so they look at
what is happening around them and they
essentially mimic it until they began to
change the way that they mimic it to be
their own right they add their own flair
to the mimicking so I don't know how to
raise kids because I don't have kids but
what I would say is the psychology of
children is about watching the adults so
be what you want them to see mm-hmm be
open to different kinds of masks you
want to be within yourself or femininity
within yourself and also within others
the way you treat the if you're a
heterosexual white cisgendered male who
has a son and you treat a gay man of a
different race religion etc however you
treat that person is how they're going
to treat that person yeah so just
modeling this wake up is probably gonna
be plenty and then it's almost as though
it's if you treat everybody with respect
then the child will treat everybody with
respect that's your role model so role
modeling is the first thing that you
would say is Cruz I think that's how we
learn so we have to look at ourselves
objectively in the mirror and work with
ourselves that introspection first one
of the things we've learned in doing the
inclusion work we do with big
corporations Price Waterhouse Cooper and
any other StubHub etc the men who have
daughters seem to be the first men to
come forward as allies because they
recognize that the world is challenging
for their daughter in a different way
that it is for their sons yeah and they
want to change the world around them so
that the but by the time their daughter
gets into the workplace it's different
it's better for her so interesting so we
have found now I would love that that
wouldn't be true I love for all men to
see this is something is structurally
wrong here can I do something about it
but I'll take what I can get and
typically that's men who have daughters
it takes birthing a daughter into the
world in order for the guy to be like
the world that she's going into his
[ __ ] up it needs to be augmented it
needs to be augmented to the most level
I think it's just as an observer
he's empathizing with a girl in a
different way than he ever has before
yeah as his offspring that's why there's
more energy put in right yeah and I that
that's not what got me into this work it
was a very dear friend who had a very
challenging thing happened her that was
violent and I wanted to figure out how
to fix it solve it cure it that was my
wake-up call everybody has a different
wake-up call but we are finding that men
with daughters start to look around the
world that their daughters are growing
up in and saying how can i as a guy in
any position of privilege do something
to change this and the better man
conference is coming up on Friday the
better man conference is this Friday in
San Francisco and we also have a second
conference in New York on November 6th
and this is once a year for one day
right now it is this is our third year
doing the third year yep and this one we
got one an SF one in New York right so
your first year doing two cities yes
good stuff congratulations on the
progress yeah that's a tree 400 people
at ten this is a big deal now it's
growing the first year we were thrilled
to have I think 120 or 140 people in the
room
actually about split demographically so
55% men and 45% women now you've been to
the women in tech conference yeah you
know when you go to an inclusion
conference it's typically women and like
a very minority of men this was just
great it was great yeah so that was
really great and we just kept going
there was no market for this when we
started it was very challenging to get
going and we're finding that especially
since the election and the me to
movement and Weinstein coming out has a
problem companies want to do something
they want to change this there are a lot
of good men in the positions of power in
our world who want things to be better
who are waking up to their to their
privilege to change something and are
leveraging it so the better man
conference is a way to start doing that
yeah rallying together the next
generation of leadership in equality I
love it I love it it's the future
it's a future of masculinity yeah it is
it is there's no there's no future of
masculinity that I see that's not
prostitutes not prosperous the one that
I see where there's not equality of
opportunity yeah it looks disgusting
looks disturbing it looks like a big
fight it looks like a big revolution and
I don't want to be a part of that
bloodbath or that suffering I want to be
a part of of equality of opportunity I
want to be a part of the future of
masculinity yeah yeah being vulnerable
and loving and calm and caring towards
people and that that's that's the future
I agree and and it's my experience that
the majority of men want that future I
have I fundamentally believe men are
good at heart want to be good the
balance of men believe in the
possibility of collaboration with women
and equality with women and and others
they just don't know I think we're to do
the work yeah so that's where we come in
wait exactly yeah yeah thousands of
times I've worked with groups of men and
individual men on learning to assert
their privilege in ways that helps
others around them
and things change corporations entirely
change when one company that employs a
hundred thousand people changes their
culture that's a big change huge it's a
massive change yeah yeah it's so
interesting that Google and all these
other companies that a prioritized
diversity inclusion and all these other
things have been so scrutinized for it
and it might have just been the most
important thing that they could have
been doing all along
does it go too far at times possibly you
might be sacrificing meritocracy in some
places does that mean that we actually
now know that maybe those sacrifices
were actually maybe more worthwhile
because the what they gain for
neurodiversity was actually
significantly more so this is all new
stuff to unpack and continue digesting
really and an understanding well it's
time to get involved to be honest with
you if you're a guy who wants who
believes himself to be a good man
the silence while you're considering
what to do can be perceived as a tacit
approval of what's happening around it's
true sir allottee can be in action yeah
neutrality is in action so if you think
about it in a game a sense of a game if
you sit still for a turn you're likely
to get hit Will Rogers said people that
stand still were the ones that get
passed up right yeah so be present with
I don't know what's going on exactly I
feel like I have some privilege but I
don't know exactly where to assert it
and start to show up your body in the
right place can do a lot of good going
to the women in tech conference is a
great way to do it
order in better to the better man
conference great way to do it yeah yeah
and then and then the waste to open up
like one-on-one with each other would be
like what would be a good way to have
like two guys or guy and a girl or
whatever how would it be how would you
guide an opening up session the way I do
it is I just say do you have any like
good friends who you connect with about
life stuff real stuff and most guys say
no not really like emotion is we do you
like is anybody supporting you in your
real life because most the guys I see
have drinking buddies work and work yeah
everybody's drinking buddies from
drinking buddies to friends that's the
gap you have to make and the gap is very
simple and all you have to do is say hey
I really appreciate our friendship and
let's like what's going on with you in
your real life
let's get real damn the drinking buddies
things like you go out and grab a beer
and you talk about whatever that's not
related to your emotion or your like
family or your most vulnerable spots
yeah but you're wanting to talk about
real stuff everybody's there for like I
just need to be around a guy who gets it
and you can just say that out loud I
just need to be around a guy who gets it
can you can I talk for a second about
what's going on with me in my
relationship
yeah okay most guys are super open to
that because they need help too and as
long as there's a strong sense of like
authenticity and like genuine interest
in what you're saying and like they
don't just transition to talking about
what about the next thing that
surface-level after you finished talking
because then it's like you didn't even
and if you don't have friends like that
in your life get some get some through
going to cool organizations in your
local area so we have cool things like
circling Institute that help with things
like this bingo
yeah we were talking about lichens on
dudes a second sunk culture there's so
many orgs and meetups that focus on that
that slow paced meditative of the center
and SF is a good one as well like yogic
practices you don't have to do it alone
is the point you don't have to do it
alone yeah find find them as soon as
that's a good action items to find the
heart centric yeah you have people to do
this with I mean veterans go to the VFW
and they do it probably weekly and I sit
around and they talk about their
feelings so if the toughest guys in the
world can do this you can yeah that's
right that's right deal just one
question on the way out we typically ask
our guests is what do you think is the
most beautiful thing in the world
I'm tempted to say the top of a mountain
I think that's probably it
the few times in my life where I have
felt completely what like awake have
been at the tops of mountains and why
it's just presents like your for me it's
a it's a culmination points like let me
just be fully present with this point
this moment and within that presence
there's usually I think Vista beauty and
space and fresh air and things like that
but typically for me getting to the top
of a mountain usually in choir requires
a hike
of some kind and so there's a sense of
accomplishment a sense of being in life
being present yep yeah yep and there's
also something interesting about the
vibration that might go up to that peak
from Earth yeah feeling up there there
either
mountains are a place where change
happened millennia ago yeah so going to
a place that seems so set but
recognizing that it is the literal point
of upheaval on the planet it's a nice
dichotomy for me that's a really good
fit cuz I think life is all about being
present in the moments of upheaval
recognizing what you're set yeah given
these bird's eye view
yeah I love perspective that's my
favorite yeah do a while what a freaking
pleasure this has been thank you so much
on the show yes great yeah this is only
you know this only beginning of the
future of masculinity truly yeah and
thank you for your work in the space 15
years of this like this has been a long
ride for you and we really appreciate it
thank you thanks for caring
hopefully you're open we got you know we
have we've had great people from like
certainly circling Institute on the show
before and Aurora Quinto more from yeah
Susie Essman Sun culture and I hope you
know it's good that we made those intros
and and I so that you guys can connect
but I hope the conversation rolls with
more people around the world in this in
this respect there's a lot to open
ourselves up to outside of the box says
that hold us back the box is that
culture and the political economic
systems put us into so if we can figure
out how to get outside of those boxes
and explore what's outside of them to
best be ourselves let's do that together
give us your comments below we'd love to
hear your thoughts we would also like to
recommend you to go and
go create go manifest your destiny into
the world if this type of show and
content gives you good feelings good
energy moving forward good knowledge
we'd greatly appreciate your support our
patreon and cryptocurrency links are
below and much appreciated Ron thank you
for producing and directing they'll
thank you for joining us much love
everyone
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
you